Let's look at the solution
to our memory refresh quiz.
We have a memory with 4096 rows and
this many columns.
It needs to be refreshed
every 500 microseconds.
And this is our read timing, where
these two steps and this one overlap.
So basically,
it takes us 4 plus 10 plus either 11 or
2 plus 4 nanoseconds before
we complete one read and
can proceed with the next one.
Because 2 plus 4 is 6.
And 11 nanoseconds is longer.
That means that, really, the timing for
our read will be to select a row.
So we need to select a row,
get the values from the row, and
then write the data back.
During this time,
the row needs to remain selected.
So the new read really cannot
begin until 4 plus 10 plus
11 nanoseconds into it.
So the read takes 25 nanoseconds.
And that means we could be doing 40
million reads per second if all we had
to do is do reads.
And this is where it becomes tricky,
because during a second we need
to do a number of refreshes.
The refresh period is 500 microseconds.
So the number of refreshes we have
to do it 2,000 times per second.
We need to do a refresh
of each of the rows.
To do that,
the row needs to be selected.
We need to get the bit value and
write it back, so
it takes the same time to do a refresh
of the row as it takes to do a read.
Meanwhile, our memory
cannot be doing the read.
So, really, we're expanding 2,000 x
4,096 x 25 nanoseconds on refreshes.
But because they have
the same timing as reads,
we can just compute how many
refreshes we have per second.
And we end up with 8.192
million refreshes per second.
And that means that we cannot
do all 40 million reads.
Pretty much out of these really, this
was assuming that we don't do refreshes.
So because we have to do eight and
change million refreshes, we have
that many less reads that we can do.
So the overall result here is
the difference between the two.
That's how many reads do we have left
after we have spent time on eight and
change million refreshes?
So the final answer here is
the difference between this
which is 31,808,000 reads per second.
So again, without refreshes we
would be able to do 40 million.
But because refreshes need to happen.
We only have this many
reads left in a second.